hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i'll be showing
you how to get windows media player 11
in windows xp
now obviously i have windows vista
so um this is not going to work with
windows vista because it's built into
windows system but if you're curious
about how to get this for windows xp
here we go
now to think you see in the description
right click open it in a new tab so you
can still hear this video playing in the
background i'm just going to paste it
here so i can remember to give put in
the description for you guys
it'll take you mike to microsoft.com
knows media home
where you can buy extras for windows
media player
you can buy and you can also look up
frequently asked questions for windows
media player but this is the site you'll
get to
obviously right there is the download
now button you click it once
and it'll take you to the page where i
believe it'll require yes it'll ask for
validation
and you just hit the continue button
this is exactly what you're getting
you're getting
um the 32-bit version of windows vista
or of windows um
media player 11 verse 11 right here
the publish date that is english and it
gives you an estimated time you can go
say
it'll take me about three minutes
so you can also change the language
right here i'm obviously going to choose
english and then you just hit that
continue button and it'll open right up
for you
also there are a lot of plugins for
windows media players hopefully i'll be
able to do a video for you guys on how
to install plugins for windows media
player so once done downloading you guys
will get a little box that'll ask you to
install windows media player and just
download it install it you know all the
instructions for installations
um and then it's relatively simple now
you'll get all these features playing a
song
you know you'll get that big glowing
button and the transparency yes you will
get the transparency in xp you'll get
the um get the visualizer hopefully i
can show you guys the visualizer you get
the uh search music feature it's a live
search
so if i'm trying to search for amazing a
m and there it is amazing so um
that's that's what you'll get um that's
very quick way to get windows vista's um
windows media player 11 in windows xp
so thanks for watching hope you had a
nice time and if you have any other
video tutorial ideas just send me a
personal message right after you
subscribe yes it's that button to the
right or if you're watching in this hd
it's going to be below the video
either way subscribe peace out